et voilà qui nous amène à cette question
qui agite plus que jamais le débat
public au delà même du chômage au delà
même de la crise financière que nous
avons vécu faut-il se préparer à vivre
en croissance zéro ou quasiment nul
jusque là les choses étaient assez
simple on disait après la pluie le beau
temps
après la récession la reprise est bien
cette perspective là semble s'éloigner
plusieurs livres parus dernièrement s'en
font d'ailleurs l'écho alors on va s'y
arrêter ce soir on va voir comment
certains se sont fait à cette idée de la
croissance zéro et en tire les
conséquences
on va entendre ceux qui défendent et
ceux qui s'opposent à cette idée mais
d'abord le constat bonsoir françois
lenglet pour de vivre ces dernières
années la croissance et arrêter c'est
devenu la norme
oui c'est la norme depuis quelques
années la quantité de richesses
produites en france non plus alors que
dans le même temps la population elle
continue à progresser ce qui veut dire
que la richesse par habitant décline et
c'est ça qui explique le chômage record
et la persistance de déficits élevés on
va regarder l'évolution de la croissance
en france sur 20 ans entre 1994 et 2008
le pib français fait un bond gigantesque
+ 33 % c'est considérable en 2009 le
creux marqué c'est la récession et
depuis ce plateau sur lequel nous sommes
collés c'est la croissance zéro et qui
nous paralyse le plus troublant c'est
que même les pays qui sont partis plus
vite que nous les etats unis ou bien le
royaume unis connaissent une activité
économique plus faible qu'avant la crise
l'économie mondiale semble tourner moins
bien et c'est ce qui fait dire à
certains économistes que nous pourrions
être entré dans une nouvelle ère celle
de la grande stagnation est ce qu'on
peut imaginer que la croissance s'arrête
vraiment et y at il eu dans l'histoire
des périodes des longues périodes sans
croissance
je vais vous montrer quelques chiffres
c'est la croissance mondiale sur milan
millions d'économies en fait on doit ces
chiffres un économiste renommé ses angus
maddison qui les a reconstitué à partir
de sources extrêmement rare milan milan
pendant des siècles la croissance
mondiale c'est cette ligne plate qui
végète au niveau du sol
la croissance est quasiment nul dans
tous les pays parce que les technologies
évoluent pas les enfants sont exactement
comme leurs parents
l'économie est immobile au point que
lorsque la population baisse c'est à ce
moment là que le niveau de vie progresse
commenterai 150 quand l'épidémie de
peste noire frappe l'europe
30 % des européens disparaissent les
survivants voient leur revenu progresser
un économiste britannique thomas malthus
préconise justement à partir de ce
constat en 1798 qu'on limite la
fécondité - en est nous dit il mieux on
sera
mais il se trompe lourdement parce qu'au
même moment au xviiie siècle en invente
la machine à vapeur qui déclenché la
révolution industrielle la croissance
n'est à ce moment là avec la
mécanisation avec l'industrie avec les
transports les revenus des européens
progressent il se libère petit à petit
du travail physique grâce à l'énergie
qui dope la productivité le pétrole
apparaît et puis l'électricité qui
déclenche un boom du pib mondial
deux cents ans de croissance verticale
bon surtout évidemment aux états unis et
en europe avec tout en haut
la vague d'innovations actuelle celle
que nous connaissons celle de
l'informatique communicante l'internet
le problème c'est que cette vague est
décevante elle produit moins de
croissance que celle de l'énergie
ce qui fait dire à nos économistes que
nous pourrions retrouver une ligne de
croissance plate comme avant la machine
à vapeur passionnant merci françois
alors faut-il s'habituer à cette idée
l'idée que vous évoquez l'idée que
l'accumulation a défini des richesses
est une illusion
et bien certains en ont pris leur parti
et pousse la logique jusqu'au bout
reportage laurie barman lui krikorian
avec julien duperey et donc voila mon
costume que j'ai porté pendant dix ans
ma vigne ou moins fini les costumes
cravates aujourd'hui l'outil de travail
de didier flins c'est sa bêche et son
râteau
depuis deux ans cet ancien directeur
financier a emménagé dans cette ferme
dans le cher avec sa compagne et ses
deux enfants
avant le couple gagner 5000 euros par
mois aujourd'hui ils ont divisé leurs
revenus et leurs dépenses par deux moins
d'argent mais une nouvelle vie moins
stressante pour toute la famille en fait
il se noyer dans son travail voilà pour
ramener de l'argent qui finalement ne
nous servait pas à grand chose
et du coup un individu qui est pas
heureux dans son travail n'est pas
heureux dans sa vie de famille dans son
couple ça a des répercussions sur tout
le monde dans la famille pour assurer
les fins de mois didier travaille comme
consultant quelques jours par semaine le
reste du temps il est à la ferme avec
marion entre culture et activités
pédagogiques tout dans leur quotidien a
changé plus question de mettre les pieds
au supermarché le garde-manger est à
portée de main avant je travaillais dix
heures par jour dans un bureau donc
d'exporter mon bureau j'allais dans un
magasin quoi jeter acheter ce qu'il
fallait le petits plats tout prêts pour
manger ça devant dont la télé le soir
quoi
et aujourd'hui eh ben on vient de
décider le menu ensemble on fait dans
mon jardin et prend les côtes de bettes
et on allait chercher les oeufs dans le
poulailler c'est leur philosophie fuir
la surconsommation et c'est quand même
fou d'être d'une dans un système
économique qui dépend du consommateur
que s'il continue pas d'acheter des
choses dont il n'a pas besoin avec de
l'argent qu'il n'a pas le système
économique ces fonds c'est ça c'est pour
moi c'est vraiment pour du coup un non
sens on va se manger cette omelette
bhl est e haricots tout sur cette table
vient des animaux et du jardin les
parents ont renoncé aux produits
transformés et à l'avion d'industriels
au grand dam des enfants qu'est ce qui
te manque la danse que tu penses que tu
manges corps dans le bleu
croque-monsieur ndar garnements mange
encore un tel défaut
la croissance zéro dans leur esprit ça
passe aussi par un chauffage naturel
désormais c'est ce poêle à bois qui
chauffe toute la maison un changement
radical qui a nécessité quelques
adaptations
on a une maison à plusieurs niveaux donc
en hiver tout le monde s'installe au
rez-de-chaussée et on chauffe que avec
la cuisinière et c'est pas contraignant
de devoir tous dormir en bas dans la
même chambre
non et pourtant de retrouver nos espaces
au printemps mais durant l'hiver savard
c'est juste la bonne période et ici pas
de télévision pas de tablettes ou de
consoles de jeux pour les enfants de 7
et 9 ans toutes mes copines à chaque
fois kevin là eh ben elle n'arrive pas à
trouver le jeu cave ou dans le faire
parce que j'ai pas les mêmes affaires
qu'elle dans ma nouvelle jv j'aime bien
parce que le la des animaux en ennemis
croates forêt la famille n'a pas
l'impression de vivre dans un monde
archaïque
loin d'être un retour en arrière pour
nous c'est une avance en avant puis on a
internet nos remparts on l'avait pas qui
est important dans la vie c'est de faire
des choix et de type c'est un choix
c'est un choix on a envie de le faire au
quotidien
cette chasse aux gaspillages passe aussi
par les transports plus question d'aller
en ville tous les jours
les déplacements en voiture sont
regroupés
si je prends ma voiture pour aller à
l'école et que j'ai du courrier à poster
et que
je dois prendre du pain schl et tout en
même temps j'ai pas faire trois trajets
dans la journée un changement de vie qui
selon eux les a rendus plus heureux dans
l'avenir grâce aux animaux et à la ferme
la famille s'est même fixé un nouvel
objectif l'autosuffisance
alors faut-il croire à la fin d'une
époque celle d'une croissance à 3 ou 4 %
voire davantage et bien voici les
arguments des uns et des autres chacun
se fera son idée
philippe boisserie avec christophe
devaux lembras emmanuel zadok la réponse
courte est ce que c'est la fin de la
croissance et oui si on regarde en
europe ce qui se passe depuis 2007 à peu
près partout la production industrielle
est en train de baisser à peu près
partout les constructions sont en train
de baisser à peu près partout les
transports en camions sont en train de
baisser
donc si on regarde un certain nombre de
flux physiques qui font notre économie
ils sont déjà partis à la baisse en
europe depuis 2007
moi je pense qu'on est tout à fait
capable d'atteindre une croissance de 2%
par an de 2 et demi pour cent par an n'y
a pas de raison qu'on n'y arrive pas et
sur une durée longue mais ça requiert de
réformer nos institutions et nos
politiques en profondeur dans un monde
dans lequel s'est essentiellement les
machines qui travaillent à notre place
et les machines manche de l'énergie
c'est l'approvisionnement énergétique
qui fait la croissance est absolument
pas les gens au travail depuis les chocs
pétroliers et 74 79
on est en excès de travail et du chômage
partout on est en excès de capital il ya
des bulles spéculatives partout par
contre on a commencé à être en
ralentissement sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique et c'est ça qui fait que
l'économie n'est pas reparti après les
chocs pétroliers et c'est du reste pour
la même raison que malheureusement je
pense que la prochaine crise n'était ce
pas c'est que de deux à trois ans à
partir d'aujourd'hui comment peut-on
donner limites à ce qu'on peut découvrir
quand tu as eu la révolution
d'électricité on n'avait pas prévu la
révolution d'internet et quand il est
leur évolution de la machine à vapeur
on n'avait pas prévu la révolution
d'électricité on veut une société
d'innovation et bien par définition sont
des sociétés en croissance parce qu'elle
génèrent de nouvelles idées je ne crois
pas du tout à la fin de la croissance
je crois qu'au contraire le les
opportunités d'idées nouvelles et
d'interaction intellectuels vont ne vont
faire qu'augmenter au cours du temps
tous les régimes de redistribution les
retraites la sécurité sociale etc toutes
les augmentations à l'ancienneté
tout ce système là lui a besoin de la
croissance pour rester stable et si nous
n'avons plus de croissance on
déstabilise tous ces systèmes et donc il
va y avoir un temps d'ajustement qui lui
va être très compliqué pour un monde
politique qui pour le moment n'y a pas
réfléchi une demi seconde pour retrouver
la croissance durable il faut que nous
devenions compétitif c'est à dire qu'il
faut qu ils vraiment nos produits qu'on
fasse des produits ou pas cher ou de
très bonne qualité pour satisfaire la
demande croissante qui va venir des pays
émergents et ça nous l'aurons qu'avec
des marchés du travail et des biens et
services beaucoup plus flexible beaucoup
plus mobile et bien là nous serons en
mesure de bien d'avoir de très bonnes
perspectives de croissance
voilà pour cette page spéciale et ces
quelques éléments de réflexion